maybe something's your boy John's cat
bold freaky Zeki she was saying Tana and
you already know is Dipset on the box
[Music]
diplomat diplomat is just us moving and
grooving and then Monday we just started
a chant talking about we Harlem or
diplomats or for the master p-chan time
an old lemon sold your daughter told you
and we started doing a Harlem or dipping
that chant just like that on my Harlem
world diplomat in this stuff this is not
the original Dipset piece but it's you
know it was made over classic diplomat
bird this legendary Walter I mean I
don't even know just know anything like
legendary six-figure dig is the one that
came up with a diplomat logo and okay if
you look at the back of a dollar I'll
show you the logo and that's what it was
all about diplomats it's all about a
dollar that's how he came up with the
logo and Digger was like I put the ego
and you slept different mats across in
and started making t-shirts and [ __ ]
like that this one is working about on
thirty five forty five grand
this is a classic ap let me all show
that's the original ap yeah yeah yeah
chunky monkey right they got the
skeletons yeah I got a few more pieces
of dust in police custody right now that
I couldn't bring I got an old gold
window that's not busted down just and
that was actually like 75 that was like
55,000 I believe what I paid for this
yesterday day rule is fully bust down I
like all of those long as I got some
water in it okay they all look pretty
well my wife Christie she got more
watches than a lot of people she got
this sea-dweller the sky dweller she
dwelling
it's a little plain Janie right here you
know I'm saying yeah and this is more
sophisticated look for for a gentleman
you know I'm anything you ain't trying
to do too much you know I understand but
you trying to say you have you know your
day these pieces right here this is a
grandmother piece you know I'm saying
these two pieces you did what I'm saying
just something like I said on a census
since the mention my cousin gada he
wears this you know I'm says we feel in
certain days and just to get a spirit
I'll let him drop sometime you know I'm
saying this is this right here this I
call this the splash dance you know I
mean because usually when the ladies and
I'm saying they they get to look at it
and they hide water when they see it as
well he'll I don't know why it's
Illmatic like that but when they look
the eyes get the dripper even the water
is wet here get watery and all of that
so and did you lock steady on it you
know I'm saying and it's just to end it
all with Levi's here this is this is arm
it's my engagement ring that my ladies
on game is white gold do you think the
crush ice you know I'm saying this is
this is Ice Cube this is this is Ice
Cube NWA you did you're here now saying
you wear that every day yes I will help
job this [ __ ] I better way to sit every
day I wonder if I almost take this off I
think my finger gonna come off with it
cuz she not playing you not me
he's right hey I bought a couple chains
these big boys though these right here
then tennis tennis chains I guess they
would call them Serena these is this one
is half a carets worn this one is 60
pointers 80 point is almost a carrier
that's a set you know that's pretty much
what I like to wear every day cuz it's
like it is a lot but in this like it's
still sexy at the end of the day it's
not like it's not like my super big
Cubans that I have that's just like you
know any kind of making my neck hurt
after a while I'm not even gonna front
this could be like one one engagement
ring depending on who you are it was
almost at this ya know everything to get
with the chain alone is almost like a
hundred and the piece alone is probably
about 45 to 50 and white white crosses
you have a lot of crosses across his
dancing on water or you know they say
Jesus walked on water
yeah something like that maybe that's
how you can explain that one this is all
like VL piece 2-tone Rose Bowl or white
of little chunky for a vamp life vo
event like me and that's my company it's
called vampire life as a company I
started with t-shirts and there's grew
up for me it's a record label and
everything else I do
there's a coffin from out of VL coffin
we own the night this is 20 grand don't
it oh the cultural overs oh yeah there's
waste in the cause I used to keep $500
in there I think I spent it one day
that's a rope chain Oh Scooby boy a rope
chain
yeah MCMC with it
Cuban link grace is fully bust dance
bound my strategy here I believe this
one is a 25,000 I want to say this one
is like 15,000 and I'm gonna say like
this one's like 10,000 it's called a
trilogy because of it this will go it's
fully bossy though your honor
this is a Dipset ring so this ring is
about 17 years old right now it's my
engagement ring autumn are autumn all
shaped bring small stones around the
size and [ __ ] like that but he W deck is
dumb he put them on back to your temple
though man I ain't got a double of my
face ring this is bringing me a wing
bored a while ago I still got it I bring
this up noxious you got like a six carat
stone in the middle and it's just like
one it's nice though this is why here's
five thousand dollars that's a fact just
cost more than [ __ ] real jury they got
it on the [ __ ] like that this explains
this in this is silver things back yeah
we said a lot of these trends that a lot
of these upcoming rappers and rappers
are going we from New York so when you
just tend to look at the game everything
started here when it comes to the style
and charisma and all of that type of
[ __ ] but as far as setting these trends
and how you should look as a rapper and
a b-boy and all that all come to zero
for me exactly they all get there from
here whole is my son he need over from
school boys I think it was alone you
need over my all you do your homework
all right I'm gonna send you over right
to my homework dad in the end I stay in
school to do my homework dad who do you
guys think has the best story collection
no looking
right now in the game yeah Gucci man got
it booty man got it after Gucci I would
say filthy rich we got a great
collection to thank him on Oh 95% of
these rappers out here but he got pieces
for every call to rave the Bentley truck
the BMW I he got pieces that match every
car losing his mom with Julie
I'm ready from he was a time I feel like
I was in the king of Joo Gucci got it
right now
I like Gucci you got it right now you
know me but you know I'd ever know that
let's have that water the strongest kid
yes you did you guys have plans for next
piece this is actually the piece that we
gonna have made the Purple Heart piece
to have purple stones and a diplomate
stone The Diplomat burr before we bust
down it's gonna be a people be at peace
I got this [ __ ] coming so I got a chair
never chain like this it's like 700
grams then I made from one of my other
chain gangs and I got a big-ass coffin
being made with the man inside so we
open the door got the man inside and all
that type of [ __ ] from be Skeletor you
quarks colors you're gonna be walking
around with a body on your body body
body body or the body it's a home 25
right here money you're a [ __ ] mm-hmm
that's not around good you love me
Millie raucous laugh watching you get a
bus down you still gonna get that 50 for
that bussy Rolex you getting you getting
damn it there's money you spent for it
now some things look good but they ain't
good ain't good investments like a call
they're just my she ate this [ __ ] know
your old one it is yeah thank me later
[Music]